you
[Applause]
in 1969 I was standing behind the
Sylvania black-and-white television set
hearing about these things happening on
the set in the front I was the guy you
know looming the rabbit ears for my dad
and my sister my mom they'll move over
here turn over here move this way we
can't see the screen and what they were
watching was one small step for a man
one giant leap for mankind
Neil and Buzz Aldrin were walking on the
moon and I was five years old in
Lynchburg Virginia a skinny black kid
and the kind of somewhat racist town and
I was trying to figure out what I was
gonna do with my life and my parents you
know they were educators they said that
you know you can do anything but after
that moon landing all the kids in the
neighborhood were like you gonna be an
astronaut I'm like no I don't want a
buzz cut and I don't see someone who
looks like me because representation
does matter and I knew that there was a
guy five blocks down the street on
Pierce Street who was training to play
tennis and it was Arthur Ashe and my dad
talked about his character his
discipline his intelligence his
athleticism I wanted to be Arthur Ashe I
don't build a moon guys and as I went on
and through this journey my dad was a
schoolteacher he played in a band he did
all these things to make money for my
sister and I had to take piano lessons
and do these different things with
education and he one day decides to
drive up into the driveway with this
this bread truck and I'm thinking okay
bread truck me delivering bread while my
dad's driving the truck I'm like okay
I'm a good bread guy now but he says
this is our camper and like dude come on
I can read Laurita bread and rolls on
the side of this truck and he says no
we're gonna build this into our camper
and over that summer we rewired the
entire entire electrical system we
plumbed a propane tank into a Coleman
stove we
build bunk beds to flip down we were
turning this into our summer vacation
launchpad escape pod this thing that
could take us out of Lynchburg and
before that I was actually raped at five
by some neighbors and I didn't tell
anyone because I had friends that didn't
have fathers and I knew that my father
would have killed the people they did
that to his son and I don't want my
father to be gone so as we got in this
bread truck and escaped from Lynchburg
it was my time with my dad and we went
to the Smoky Mountains I looked at the
purple mountains majesty and we we
walked along the beach in Myrtle Beach
and this thing was was transformative it
showed me what it meant to be an
explorer at a very early age and I
suppressed all that negativity all that
trauma because I was learning to be an
explorer and a little bit later my
mother gave me an agent appropriate non
OSHA certified chemistry set where I
created the most incredible explosion in
her living room and so I knew I could be
a chemist so as I went on this journey
through a high school and went to
college and I got a football scholarship
to play football in college and I knew
that I could be a chemist because I'd
already blown stuff out and when I
graduated I got drafted to the Detroit
Lions but I pulled a hamstring in
training camp and so what every former
NFL player does they go work for NASA
right so I went to work for NASA and
this friend of mine said Leland you'd be
a great astronaut I just laughed at him
I was like yeah me an astronaut you know
that Neil and Buzz thing from back in 69
and he had him an application and I
looked at it and I didn't fill it out
and that same year another friend of
mine showed off the application and he
got in and I said to myself if NASA's
letting knuckleheads excited to be
astronauts
maybe I can be one too so the next
election I fill out the application and
I got in and I didn't know what it meant
to be an astronaut the training the
simulations all these things to get you
ready for this countdown three two one
liftoff and in 2007 I was in space
shuttle Atlantis careening off the
planet traveling at 17,500 miles per
hour in eight and a half minutes later
the main engines cut off and we're now
floating in space and I push off and
float over to the window and I can see
the Caribbean and I need new definitions
of blue to describe the colors that I
see as your indigo navy blue medium navy
blue turquoise don't do any justice to
what I see with my eyes and my job on
this mission was to install this 2
billion dollar Columbus laboratory was a
research laboratory for Materials
Research for human research and I
reached into the payload bay of the
space shuttle grabbed out this big
module and I used the robotic arm and I
attached it to the space station and the
Europeans had been waiting 10 years for
this thing to get installed so I'm sure
everyone in Europe was like Leela and so
this moment happened this was our
primary mission objective it was done
and I had this big sigh of relief but
then Peggy Whitson the first female
commander she invited us over to the
Russian segment of the space stations
about the size of a football field with
solar panels and trusses and all of
these modules and she says Leland you go
get the rehydrated vegetables we'll have
the meat so we float over with a bag of
vegetables all rehydrated and we get
there and there's this moment where I
get transform back to my mother's
kitchen you can smell the beef and
barley heating up you can smell the the
food the colors and they're people they
are from all around the world it's like
a Benetton commercial your head
african-american asian-american French
German Russian
the first female commander breaking
bread at 17,500 miles per hour going
around the planet every 90 minutes
seeing a sunrise and a sunset every 45
and Peggy would say hey Leland try some
of this and she'd float over to my mouth
I catch it and we go back and forth and
we're doing all of this while listening
to Sade smooth I mean this is like
blowing my mind you know and I float
over to the window and I look down at
the planet and I see all of humanity and
my perspective changes at that moment
because I'm flying over Lynchburg
Virginia my hometown and my family's
probably breaking bread and five minutes
later we're flying over Paris where Leo
I hearts is looking down at his parents
how about having some wine and cheese
and URIs looking off to Moscow and
they're probably eating Borash there's
something else but we're all having this
moment where we see our respective
families working together as one
civilization
it's 17,500 miles per hour my
perspective shifted cognitively it
changed me and when I think about being
that little skinny boy from sometimes
racist Lynchburg Virginia I would never
have had that that perspective to think
about myself of being an astronaut if my
father hadn't taken us on a journey in
this radical craft that we built with
our own two hands when I came home I
realized that perspective is something
that we all get and we all have
it's just how far do we open up our
blinders to see that that shift in that
change and going back to the space
station I I think of you know Germans
and Russians fighting Americans we have
these people living and working together
white folks black folks Russian folks
French folks you know all these
different people coexisting in harmony
is one race and I think about the colors
that I saw the design of the modules the
way that things fit
gather the way that it made us a
community our home and so when I look up
to space now and I have this newfound
perspective on the space station going
overhead and looking there and then
looking back at my community and seeing
the people that I'm living and working
with and coexisting with I think it's
something that we all can do now
especially in these times to make sure
that we have the right perspective thank
you if you don't mind could I just chat
with you from enemies they're gonna set
up some some things here and and I I get
to have you all to myself
right so I have to tell you that in my
family we watch a lot of space movies
about astronauts and stuff like that I
can't tell you why but we do that the
thing that I wanted to ask you though is
that I was we were seeing this movie the
other day and it was about one of the
astronauts one of your colleagues and
before he went up into space they
actually wrote an obituary NASA wrote an
obituary for him and I was like it's
that normal and it's like that part of
the job but you think about that peril
that you're putting yourself in as you
go into space yeah um so I don't
remember anyone writing my obituary
maybe that was an Apollo Day thing but I
do know that it would mean in the 135
shuttle flights that we've had that the
fellow that I flew along we had two
accidents that you know killed everyone
on that on that mission and we all know
the perils and the risks that go along
with this but we're doing something
that's much bigger than ourselves and
helping advance civilization so the risk
is worth the reward and we all feel that
way when we get in that vehicle and
strap into those million pounds of you
know rocket fuel and yeah and go to
space yeah I mean I've only seen the
Hollywood version it looks pretty
terrifying
one way trip were to a debate
III wanted to if if I may I mean you you
did touch on something that was very
powerful and and difficult which is you
spoke about this incident that have
happened to you when you were five years
old and that you were raped and I just
think that for you to be able to say
those things you know on the Ted stage
to be able to talk about that at all is
is pretty fearless and I and I wanted to
get a sense from you is that is that
something that you think is is it's
important for you to share that now to
just speak about it right it's so
important especially for men to talk
about things that have happened because
we've been trained and told by our
society that we have to be so tough and
so hard and we can't tell us things that
are happening to us but I've had so many
men contact me and tell me that you came
through that you got over that I'm gonna
get over my alcoholism and my these
things that are going in them because of
what happened to them and so we must
share these stories this is part of
storytelling to heal us and to make us
whole as a as a community no that's
[Music]
and and you know quite honestly you
spoke about perspective shift and that
is a shift that I think we've been very
slow to accept and to be able to speak
about that so we we thank you for that
we thank you for being the amazing
astronaut that you are and thank you for
coming to the Ted stage Leland solution